thank you thank you as usual a great
crowd this is a week three for my home
I'm I'm Bill Maher I'm putting the home
in home box office
and you know I love my home oh I love
home sweet home home home but enough of
home I never thought I would miss
traffic you know like my commute today
brutal there was a two dog pile up in
the kitchen one was overturned the other
was leaking gas
[Applause]
thank you yeah it's it's lonely I'm not
gonna lie it's lonely around here I'm
like one of those old widows who just
waits for the mailman to come so I have
some sort of human contact lately I've
been leaving homemade cookies and
lemonade it's it's it said last night my
dick said it wanted to start seeing
other hands it's it's it's rough around
here a few days ago I was watching at
the movie once upon a time in Hollywood
terrific movie and that scene where Brad
Pitt answers the door and it's the
Manson Family and I thought ooh company
really I am afraid I am losing it I I am
this close to writing a manifesto I
last week I took mushrooms and facetimed
with future mean
[Applause]
no I and you know I'm not the only one I
know I'm not my some of my sober friends
I know they're drinking again I was
facetiming with this guy last week I saw
in the background he had a bottle of
scotch which he tried to pass off his 12
year old hand sanitizer but you know
there's there's help on the way I don't
know if you saw it this week but former
President Obama made a video endorsing
Joe Biden and Biden says he cannot wait
to find a kid to show him how to play
Trump of course had a week that even by
his standards was off the rails
including flirting with the idea of
firing dr. anna falchi I mean Trump said
look it's hard enough navigating this
crisis without someone interjecting
facts and science and you know Americans
now are of course waiting for their
$1200
stimulus checks which pop perhaps have
been delayed because Trump had to put
his name on them I mean is it really
necessary to see his name on the check
to who would know who it's from are we
gonna know what it bounces
and he has apparently started a feud
with the World Health Organization which
has not been perfect but I mean it is
the World Health Organization we
probably could use it right now but he's
threatening to stop funding them because
he says the World Health Organization
has mismanaged the spread of the corona
virus the World Health Organization has
mismanaged he also says the World Health
Organization has outrageous air and
where is way too much orange makeup
you